At the Mid - America Earthquake Center, you can see what would happen...
...to your cabinets, computers, televisions, and family should the ground underneath start to shake.
The Institute for Business and Home Safety says....
...there are several easy and inexpensive steps you can take inside your house to make it safer.
These include anchoring bookcases and filing cabinets to the wall,...
...installing ledge barriers on shelves, putting heavier things lower,...
...and attaching breakables directly to the shelves with museum wax or Velcro to keep them from falling;...
...attaching computers to desks, small appliances to counter tops,...
...and anchoring large appliances like refrigerators or water heaters to the walls.
Many of these simple changes cost just a few dollars,...
...a little more if you're going to hire outside help.
The more you do, the stronger your home will become.